Next question today is David.
So in the end, should Michael Bloomberg be
allowed into the democratic presidential debates?
So I've said this before, the DNC created
their rules for getting into the debates and
if they want to live by those those rules,
they have to die by those rules unless they
simply change them to let Michael Bloomberg
in and they've changed them.
And uh, the, the big change is that the early,
um, the, the donor requirements have been
eliminated for upcoming debates and indeed
Michael Bloomberg may get into.
And by the time you even watch this clip,
it's possible he may have already qualified
for one of the upcoming democratic debates.
So it depends on how you ask this question.
If you ask me, is this a calculated establishment
move to try to give another a more centrist
Democrat?
He's been a lifelong Republican, but okay.
He's a Democrat now and he's a centrist Democrat
at that.
The idea is put someone else in there who
might be able to deny a progressive, the presidency
who might be able to split the delegate counts
such that nobody wins.
50% plus one delegates on the first round
of voting at the DNC, such that super delegates
then come in and they can pick whoever they
want.
Then if that's the framing, then the answer
is no.
This is another way that the DNC is putting
their thumb on the scale against progressive
candidates in a democratic primary.
If you simply say to me, if someone's polling
third around 14 15% should they be in the
debates?
Dancers like, well, yeah, they should.
Right?
I mean, if, when we talk about people seeing,
continuing to say, Andrew Yang never should
have canceled his campaign, we want his voice
at the debate.
We want more voices at the debates.
We want tools, C's voice, despite the fact
that she has not a path to a single delegate.
If you want more voices, even if you don't
like them, right?
It can't be out of personal bias.
It has to really be, you want more voices?
How do you say the guy who's polling third
nationally right now shouldn't be in the debates?
So I simultaneously recognize that the entire
Bloomberg thing is people who are desperate
to prevent a progressive from being nominated
who are seeing Biden falter and Buddha edge
edge maybe become the establishment choice,
but he still got issues and Amy Klobuchar
doesn't seem to, there is a desperation for
maybe Bloomberg could come in and pick this
entire thing up or at least deny a progressive
the nomination.
That's terrible.
I hate that.
If you say someone's in third place, should
they be on the stage?
The answer is like, yeah, they should.
They should be on the stage and uh, if their
ideas are bad, they should be exposed as bad
on the stage.
So it's, there is not a clear answer here
without being a supporter of Michael Bloomberg's,
I don't find there to be a strong ideological
case to say the guy in third place shouldn't
be in the debates change my mind.
I'm open to having my mind changed on this